我觉得这张地图在不经意间，
I feel like this map inadvertently says a lot about
说出了纽约市与史坦顿岛之间的微妙关系
the relationship that New York City has with Staten Island
就像它虽然在那儿，却被塞到了角落里，
like it's there but it's tucked away in the corner
其显示比例完全误导了它的真实规模
and it's completely deceptive of its size
我知道这与其说是真正的地图，不如说更像是一张示意图
and I know that this is more a diagram than an actual map
但它在我对史坦顿岛的认知形成过程中，起到了很大的引导作用
but it played a large role in shaping my perception of Staten Island
我敢打赌，有这种感觉的人绝对不止我一个
and I'm willing to bet I'm not alone
事实上，史坦顿岛比曼哈顿更长，土地面积也更大
in reality Staten Island is longer than Manhattan and larger in land area
它拥有全市所有行政区中最长的街道，
it has the longest street in a single burrow in the entire city
但即便如此，它仍被称为“被遗忘的行政区”
and even with that it's known as The Forgotten burrow
这是一个人们并不真正了解、
it it's a place that people don't really know
也不真正理解其地理重要性的地方
don't really understand the significance of this location
所以我想仔细研究一下这个“被遗忘区”的地图，
so I wanted to look a little closer at the map of this forgotten burrow
看看能不能弄清楚它为何会被遗忘，
and see if I could figure out why it's considered forgotten
以及为什么它会成为纽约的一部分
and why it's part of New York
在制作这个视频之前，我大概只去过史坦顿岛一两次，
before working on this video I had been to Staten Island maybe once or twice
而且只是坐史坦顿岛渡轮过去，
and only because I rode the Staten Island Ferry
然后立刻坐下一班船回曼哈顿
and then immediately turned around and rode it back to Manhattan
抱歉迟到了，
sorry for the delay
我见到了托马斯·马托（Thomas Mato），
I met up with Thomas Mato
他是史坦顿岛的行政区历史学家
who is the burough historian of Staten Island
他接到我后，立刻开始介绍这里的历史——
he picked me up and wasted no time before getting into Theory history
他来自犹他州盐湖城，
of the from Salt Lake City Utah
好的，你面前看到的这栋建筑就是行政大楼（Borough Hall）
okay the building you see in front of you that's bur Hall okay
托马斯只是帮助我制作这个视频的
Thomas is just one of the several amazing experts
几位了不起的专家之一
that are helping me with this video
我是史坦顿岛博物馆退休的历史策展人
I'm a retired curator of history from the Staten Island Museum
你知道，我总是说，史坦顿岛的历史有什么迷人之处？
you know I always say What's So fascinating about Staten Island history
答案是：一切
and the answer is everything
史坦顿岛是组成纽约市的五个行政区之一，
Staten Island is one of the five buroughs that make up New York City
它与其他四个区截然不同，
and it's distinctly different from the rest of them
不仅仅因为它是一个岛
not because it's an island
实际上，纽约市的大部分地区都分布在几个不同的岛屿上
actually most of New York City lies across several different Islands
布鲁克林和皇后区位于一个岛上（长岛），曼哈顿本身也是一个岛
Brooklyn and Queens are on an island Long Island Manhattan is an island
布朗克斯是唯一一个
the Bronx is the only burrow
完全位于美国大陆本土上的行政区
who entirely is a part of the Mainland of the United States
但真正让史坦顿岛与众不同的，
but what does set Staten Island apart
是它与城市其他部分的距离
is its distance from the rest of the city
纽约州的最南端就在史坦顿岛上
southernmost part of New York state is on Staten Island
就在奥特布里奇跨海大桥（Outerbridge Crossing）附近，那是纽约的最南端
by the Outerbridge Crossing it's a southern most part of New York
你从我的口音就能听出来，我们在南边，对吧？
you can tell from my my accent that we're in South right
这引出了我的第一个问题：
so this leads me to my first question
为什么史坦顿岛是纽约市的一部分？
why is Staten Island part of New York City
如果你看地图，
if you look at a map
你会发现史坦顿岛离新泽西非常近，对吧？
you see how close Staten Island is to New Jersey right
即使是与纳罗斯海峡（The Narrows）相比，
the kilv co and the Arthur Kill are are minuscule
基尔凡科尔（Kill van Kull）和亚瑟基尔（Arthur Kill）也非常窄，
even compared to the Narrows
更不用说离曼哈顿那五英里的距离了
and let alone you know the five miles to Manhattan
纳罗斯海峡是布鲁克林和史坦顿岛之间距离最短的地方，
The Narrows is the shortest distance between Brooklyn and Staten Island
标志着进入纽约港的入口
marking the entrance to the New York Harbor
但当我开始仔细观察
but when I started to look closer
纽约和新泽西的这些边界线时，
at these boundary lines of New York and New Jersey
我开始产生更多的问题
I started to get a lot more questions
纽约湾有托马斯提到的那些岛屿，
the New York Bay has the islands that Thomas mentioned
比如史坦顿岛、曼哈顿和长岛，
like Staten Island Manhattan and Long Island
但还有一堆更小的岛屿
but there's also a bunch of smaller islands
如果你看埃利斯岛（Ellis Island）和自由岛（Liberty Island），
and if you look at Ellis Island and Liberty Island
这里的边界显得有些奇怪
the borders here are kind of strange
例如，自由岛位于新泽西境内，但该岛本身属于纽约
Liberty Island for example is in New Jersey but the island belongs to New York
埃利斯岛有一个非常奇怪的边界，
and Ellis Island has a very strange border
岛的这一部分属于纽约，
where this part of the island is New York
其余部分属于新泽西
and the rest belongs to New Jersey
州界线切过哈德逊河中心，
the state border cuts through the middle of the Hudson River
穿过上湾，
down through the Upper Bay
然后急转弯，将史坦顿岛包裹在内
and then takes a sharp turn and encompasses Staten Island
关于为什么会这样，流传着几种理论
and there are several theories as to why this is
其中一个很流行的是说当时举行了一场赛船，
one popular one was that there was a boat race
谁赢了赛船，谁就得到史坦顿岛
and whoever won the boat race would get Staten Island
据说如果你能在不到一天的时间里乘船绕岛一周，
supposedly if you could Circle an Island by boat in less than a day
它就属于纽约；
it would belong to New York
如果超过一天，
and if it took longer than a day
它就属于新泽西
it would belong to New Jersey
故事是说有人在大约23个半小时内完成了，
The Story Goes that someone did it in like 23 and 1/2 hours
但这个故事引发了很多疑问
but this story raises a lot of questions
YouTube频道 CGP Gray 做了一个视频试图核实这件事，
the YouTube channel cgp gray made a video trying to verify this
内容非常棒，我会把链接放在下面的描述栏里
and it's super good I'll leave it in the description below
但最终，这个故事是无法考证的
But ultimately this story isn't verifiable
这些边界的故事实际上可以追溯到
the story of these borders actually goes all the way back
最早的欧洲定居者——荷兰人
to the first European settlers here the Dutch
我想花一点时间感谢 Headspace 赞助了本期视频
I want to take a quick second to thank headspace for sponsoring this video
在你跳过之前，
and before you skip ahead
如果你打算跳过的话，
if you're planning on skipping ahead
我只想让你知道我真的很喜欢 Headspace
I just want you to know that I love headspace so much
我主动联系了他们，
that I reached out to them and asked
问他们是否愿意赞助我的一个视频，
if they would sponsor one of my videos
因为我真的很认同他们的理念
because I really believe in what they do
Headspace 是我用来辅助冥想的一款 App，
headspace is an app I use to help me with meditation
我认为优先关注心理健康，
and I think it's really important to prioritize your mental health
留出空间来处理情绪和思考真的很重要
and to just take some space process things and think
我一直在反思去年，
I've been reflecting a lot on last year
我在情感和心理上经历了一段非常艰难的时期
and I had a pretty rough p emotionally and mentally
我发现 Headspace 上的冥想课程给了我很多安慰和实用的帮助
and I found a lot of comfort and use in the meditations on headspace
他们有关于工作压力、创意灵感以及走出失恋的冥想课程
they have meditation courses on work stress on creativity working through a breakup
我觉得我用得最多的是助眠冥想
and I think the one I use the most is the sleep meditations
我晚上用它来入睡，
I use them at night to fall asleep
它总能帮我快速入睡，
and it always helps me fall asleep quickly
并拥有一整晚的高质量休息
and have a good night's rest
我可以根据个人经验告诉大家，
I can say this from personal experience
使用 Headspace 已被证明可以减轻压力并增加幸福感
that using headspace is proven to decrease stress and increase happiness
你可以使用描述栏顶部的链接
you can use the link at the top of the description
或扫描屏幕上的二维码，
or scan the QR code on the screen
获得 Headspace 60天的免费试用，
for 60 days free on headspace
看看它能如何帮助你
and see how it can help you
非常感谢 Headspace
huge thank you to headspace
我真心喜欢他们的产品，我想你也会喜欢的
I genuinely love their product and I think you will too
好了，回到关于史坦顿岛的视频
okay back to the video about Staten Island
在制作了关于曼哈顿和布鲁克林的几个视频后，
after making a couple videos about Manhattan and Brooklyn
我决定为五个行政区的每一个都制作一个视频
I decided I wanted to make one on each burrow
在布鲁克林的视频中，我谈到了一些
in the Brooklyn video I talked a bit
关于荷兰殖民地新阿姆斯特丹和新尼德兰的情况
about the Dutch colony of New Amsterdam and New Netherland
我建议在看接下来的内容之前，
and and I recommend checking out that video
先看看那个视频了解一下背景
for a little bit of context before the rest of this one
这些边界线可以追溯到荷兰时期，
these boundary lines go back to the Dutch
但他们并不是最早来到这里的人
but they weren't the first ones here
这段历史可以追溯到勒纳佩人（Lenape）之前的时代，
the history goes back to pre Lenape times
有着成百上千年的历史
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of years of History
据我们所知，当时的史坦顿岛主要居住着拉里坦人（Raritan）
what we know Staten Island is it's largely inhabited by the Raritan
拉里坦人是在历史文献中被提到最多的
the Raritan are the ones who are mentioned the most in the documents
但塔潘人（Tap Pans）可能也在此有交集
but the tap hands are probably intersecting in there
史坦顿岛上并没有真正意义上的大型村庄
there's not really major major villages on Staten Island
这些小型营地是季节性的，
it's these small encampments that are there seasonally
在史坦顿岛上发现了一些墓葬，
there are a few burials that are found on Staten Island
里面有一些非常独特的贸易商品
that have some pretty exotic trade goods that are found
比如来自佛罗里达沿海的贝壳，
shells coming from Coastal Florida
德鲁（Drew）帮我了解了一些荷兰人到达时史坦顿岛的样子，
Drew helped me understand a bit of what Staten Island was like
我叫德鲁·查普特·拉维斯（Drew Chapter Ravis）
when the Dutch arrived
my name is Drew chapter Ravis
我是一名专门研究17和18世纪的历史复原员
I a living historian of the 17th and 18th century
我是波科莫克印第安部落（Pocomoke Indian Nation）的公民和文化大使
I'm a citizen and cultural ambassador of the pokoke Indian Nation
我们是马里兰州一个规模较小、未被承认的部落社区
we are a small unrecognized tribal community in the state of Maryland
我在纽约新阿姆斯特丹历史中心担任他们的阿阿尼（Aanii）和历史顾问
for New Amsterdam history Center as their aanii and historical consultant
我们知道史坦顿岛当时被称为“Aquehonga Manacknong”，
so what we know Sten island is that it is called aonga manong
意为“坏森林之地”
the place of bad woods
可能是指那方面
could be talking about that
那里没有太多的淡水资源
there's not a ton of fresh water that's there
荷兰人显然是第一批
the Dutch were obviously the first people to meet up with the elenae
在史坦顿岛登陆并与勒纳佩人接触的人
when they landed on Staten Island
他们在一个叫“供水站”（The Watering Place）的地方建立了一个小定居点，
and they set up a little Colony at a place called The Watering Place
也就是现在的汤普金斯维尔（Tomkinsville）
which is where tomkinsville is
但它并没能维持太久，因为后来与勒纳佩人发生了一场战争
and it didn't last because there was a war with the Lenape
之后又有两次建立永久定居点的尝试
then there were two more attempts at per settlement
而那两次也都因与勒纳佩人的战争而告终
and those two ended with war with the lape
最终在1661年，人们申请
and finally in 1661 it was petitioned
在史坦顿岛上建立一个永久定居点
to set up a permanent settlement on Staten Island
那个定居点后来被称为 Oude Dorp，在荷兰语中意为“老镇”
and that settlement was later called oorp which means old town
但在 New Dorp 建立之前它并没有名字，所以它就成了 Oude Dorp
but it had no name until New Dorp was established so it became odor
在现在的史坦顿岛，它被称为 Old Town
and in present day Staten Island it's called arrow car
现在已经没人再用 Oude Dorp 这个词了
nobody really uses the term term oorp anymore
但他们确实会说 New Dorp
but they do say newor
虽然这个社区现在叫阿罗查尔（Arrochar），
although the neighborhood is now called aerocar
但这条唯一的铁路线上的一个车站仍叫 Old Town
there is a stop on this singular train line called Oldtown
向南几站有一个车站叫 New Dorp
and a few stops to the South is a stop called New Dorp
Dorp 是古荷兰语中表示“城镇”的词
Dorp is the Old Dutch term for Town
它只是众多保留下来的荷兰语术语之一，包括 Staten Island 这个名字
and it's just one of the many Dutch terms that's stuck including Staten Island
这个名字是为纪念“议会总署”（States General）而命名的，
which is named for the stats general
它是当时荷兰的最高领导机构
which is the governing body of the Netherlands
荷兰留下的另一个遗产是“蟾蜍山”（Toad Hill）
another Legacy of the Dutch is Toad Hill
“Toad”在这里源自荷兰语，意为死亡
toad meaning death
在我关于布鲁克林的视频中，我谈到了终碛，
in my Brooklyn video I talked about the terminal Marine
那是冰川留下的山丘，
which are the hills that were left behind by a glacier
决定了展望公园和绿荫公墓等地的选址
that led to the placement of places like Prospect Park
and Greenwood Cemetery
这种地形也延伸到了史坦顿岛
and that crosses over into Staten Island
蟾蜍山就是其中的一部分
and Toad Hill is part of that
它高410英尺，实际上是缅因州以南整个大西洋沿岸的最高点
at 410 ft High it actually marks the tallest point
along the entire Atlantic coast south of Maine
有些人认为那里可能曾是美洲原住民和早期定居者之间发生过
some people think that may have been some kind of a battle
某种战斗的地方
between Native Americans and the early settlers up there
这就是为什么它被称为蟾蜍山
and that's why it's called Toad Hill
但在整个新尼德兰地区影响最广的荷兰词，
but the Dutch term that still reaches across most of New Netherland
是表示水道的词——“Kills”
is the Dutch term for Waterway kills
在纽约州上州有 Beaverkill 和 Catskill 山迈
in Upstate New York you have Beaverkill and the Catskill Mountains
但在史坦顿岛，你有像 Fresh Kills 或
but on Staten Island you have places like the fresh kills
Great Kills 港这样的地方
or Great Kills Harbor
而亚瑟基尔（Arthur Kill）和基尔凡科尔（Kill van Kull）是英语化的版本，
and the Arthur Kill and Kil van Cole are angelized versions
本意基本上是“背后的水道”
meaning essentially the back Waterway
这张地图显示了1655年荷兰对新尼德兰的主权主张范围
this map shows the 1655 Dutch claim of New Netherland
英国人在新尼德兰的两侧都有殖民地，
the English had colonies on either side of New Netherland
他们非常清楚纽约湾的价值
and they knew the value of the New York Bay
他们的动机与荷兰人完全不同
their motives were different than the Dutch
英国人是为了建立殖民地
the English were there to set up a colony
并扩大他们的权力和影响力
and expand their power and their influence
而荷兰人主要只是出于商业原因，
while the Dutch was really there mostly just for commercial reasons
为了赚钱
to make some money
而且荷兰人总是缺乏定居者
well the Dutch always were lacking in Settlers
他们从未拥有过庞大的人口
they never had a huge population
英国人的人数总是远超他们
the English always outnumbered them
所以当英国人在1664年驶入海湾
so when the English sailed into the bay In 1664
并告诉荷兰人他们要接管这里时
and told the Dutch they were taking it
荷兰人并没有进行太多的反抗
the Dutch didn't put up much of a fight
因为他们确实没有什么胜算
because they didn't really stand a chance
英国人将新阿姆斯特丹改名为纽约
the English renamed New Amsterdam New York
纽约和新泽西的分离就是从这时开始的
and this is when the split between New York and New Jersey began
但当时的边界非常模糊
but the borders were very vague
当国王查理二世获得新尼德兰后
when King Charles II acquired New Netherland
他把它送给了他的弟弟詹姆斯
he gave it to his brother James
他就是约克公爵
he is the Duke of York
这就是为什么它被命名为纽约
that's why it's named New York
詹姆斯反过来把这片土地的一部分送给了他的朋友们，
in turn James gave a portion of this land to his friends
这就是新泽西的诞生
this was the birth of New Jersey
但对边界的描述仅仅是
but the description of the Border was just that
它的东部以大海和哈德逊河为界
it was bounded on the East part by the main sea and part by Hudson's River
这种描述非常模糊，
pretty vague
该地区的控制权在荷兰人和英国人之间反复切换了一段时间
control over the region switched back and forth between the Dutch and English for a while
其间他们打了一些看起来非常酷的海战，
while they fought some of those really cool looking Naval battles
但最终他们不得不请求乔治国王回来核实
But ultimately they had to ask King George to come back and verify
史坦顿岛究竟属于新泽西还是纽约
if Staten Island was part of New Jersey or New York
国王判定它是纽约的一部分
and he said that it was part of New York
如果史坦顿岛属于新泽西而不是纽约，
if Staten now was part of New Jersey instead of New York
那么任何商业活动及其税收都必须由两个州共享
any Commerce and any taxes on that Commerce would have to be shared by both states
谁会想那样做呢？
and why would you want to do that
但史坦顿岛和埃利斯岛的边界线仍然不清楚
but the boundary lines of Staten Island and Ellis Island were still unclear
这实际上导致了各种争端，一直持续到1998年
and this actually led to disputes all the way up till 1998
最高法院最终裁定所有人工填海的土地都属于新泽西
the Supreme Court decided that all of the man-made land belonged to New Jersey
而所有原始土地都属于纽约
while all of the original land belong to New York
所以这条边界向你展示了岛上哪些部分是人工填海的，哪些不是
so this boundary shows you which part of the island is manmade and which isn't
尽管这两方互相讨厌，但他们真的很难决定该讨厌岛上的哪一部分
for hating on each other so much they really have a hard time deciding which part they hate
但成为纽约市一部分则是另一个故事，
but the story of becoming part of New York City is a different one
那是在英国人从荷兰人手中夺走这里后的200年才发生的
that wouldn't happen for another 200 years after the English got it from the Dutch
在最初的一段时间里，英国人控制着史坦顿岛，
during the first the English controlled Staten Island
并称之为里士满县（Richmond County）
and they called it the county of Richmond
在中心地带，他们建立了一个名为里士满镇（Richmond Town）的城镇
at the center they established a town called Richmond Town
里士满是里士满公爵的名字，
uh Richmond is was
他是查理二世的侄子
the um the Duke of Richmond was the cuz the Duke of Cu it nephew or Duke
这就是名字的由来，
that's who it's named for
它是以里士满公爵命名的
is the Duke of Richmond who was the nephew of Charles II
所以它变成了里士满镇
and that's why it becomes Richmond Town
那是殖民时代该省最初的县治所在地
well this was the original county seat for the provin
back in colonial days
这很有道理，
and it wouldn't make sense
因为在那个年代，这主要是一个农业社区
because in those days this was primarily an agricultural community
所以到处都是农场
so there were many farms
人口密集的地区并不多
and there wasn't very many dense popul populated areas
所以政府中心就设在行政区的正中间
so the city of government was right
in the middle of the burrow
非常靠近行政区的中心位置
very close to the middle of the burrow
这样离岛上各个地方的距离都相等
so it was at equidistance to All Parts
那里还有一条通往这里的入海口
there was also an inlet from the water to here
船只实际上可以一直开到这里
and ships would actually come up here
但随着时间的推移，
but over time with silk developing
由于泥沙堆积，它变得无法航行了
it became unnavigable
但当年船只确实能一直开到这里
but ships actually came all the way in here
所以它是政府中心的完美选址
so it was a perfect location for the city government
史坦顿岛现在仍然是里士满县
Staten Island is still the county of Richmond
但在1975年更名之前，
but it was actually officially the burrow of Richmond all the way up until 1975
它在官方上一直被称为里士满行政区
before it was renamed
不过我最喜欢的一点是，
one of my favorite things though is that
英国人还把里士满镇叫做“贝壳镇”（Cockled Town）
the English also called Richmond Town cockled Town
据说这源于“cockle”这个词，指的是牡蛎，
supposedly this is rooted in the word cockal referring to oysters
但不管怎样，我很开心它出现在这张地图上
but either way I'm happy it's on this map
里士满镇现在是一个历史遗址，
Richmond town is now a historic site
保存得相当完好
that's actually been pretty well preserved
这里保留了许多旧建筑，
this has many of the old buildings
还有岛上乃至全市最古老的建筑之一
and one of the oldest buildings on the island and in the city here
有些是迁过来的，有些原先就在这里
some were moved here some were originally here
历史悠久的里士满镇会让你
historic Richmond Town will give you that feel
感受到一两百年前史坦顿岛可能的样貌
of what Staten Island might have looked like 100 200 years ago
它能让你体会到当年的历史韵味
and it gives you like a flavor of what that might have been
当英国人到来时，他们对印第安人说的一件事是：
so when the English come one of the things that they tell the Indians
你们过去与荷兰人发生的所有问题都已成为过去，
is that you know all of the problems you've had with the Dutch are in the past
现在我们接手了
now we are a new man
我们是新的人民
we are a new people
过去与荷兰人之间的所有那些不快，
and all of those consider all of those problems you had with the Dutch
就让它们被遗忘吧
let it be forgotten
这也是最后一批美洲原住民被迫从史坦顿岛迁离的时候
this is also the time when the last Native Americans were displaced from Staten Island
在这一百年里，这里基本没有开发，大多只是农场，
during these hundred years it remained pretty undeveloped and was mostly just Farms
所以人口没有剧增，
so there was no dramatic increase in population
但在各殖民地宣布独立后不久，这里开始出现大量活动
but it did begin to see a lot of activity shortly after the colonies declared Independence
1776年7月初，成千上万的英国军队进入纽约港，
1776 in early July tens of thousands of British troops came into the New York Harbor
他们在史坦顿岛驻扎下来
and they settled on Staten Island
这里成为了英军在纽约市地区的总部所在地
and it became the home place for the British Army in the New York City area
随着冲突的加剧，
as a conflict gained momentum
曾有人试图就在现在的托滕维尔（Tottenville）的会议大屋（Conference House）停止独立战争
there was an attempt to stop the Revolutionary War right right here at the conference house in modern day Tottenville
这座房子由克里斯托弗·比利普（Christopher Billopp）在1680年左右建造
built by and for Christopher bilip about 1680
这座房子长期以来是殖民地好客精神的象征，
this house was long Ascent of colonial hospitality
也被称为会议大屋
is known also as conference house
因为本杰明·富兰克林、约翰·亚当斯和爱德华·拉特利奇于1776年9月11日应豪勋爵的要求在这里与他会面，
because Benjamin Franklin John Adams and Edward rutage met here with Lord how at his request on September 11th 1776
试图阻止美国革命，但未能成功
in an unsuccessful effort to hold the American Revolution
海军上将理查德·豪对他们说
Lord Admiral Richard H said to them
如果殖民地能重新归顺并向国王效忠，
if the colonies would just come back into the fold and pledge allegiance to the king
一切都将被赦免
all will be forgiven
你们不会受到惩罚，
and there will be no you know you won't be reprimanded
不会被征收更多的税，也不会受到处罚
you won't be taxed any further you won't be punished
只要回来，一切都既往不咎
just come back and all will be forgiven
显然这并没有发生，
obviously that didn't happen
战争期间英国人占领了史坦顿岛
and during the war the English occupied Staten Island
他们加固了纳罗斯海峡附近原有的荷兰防御工事，该工事实际上一直运行到1994年，
they fortified a pre-existing Dutch fortification near the Narrows that actually continued in operation all the way up till 1994
成为美国持续使用时间最长的军事设施
making it the longest continuously Used military installation in the United States
那些是当时主要放置大炮的炮台，
and those are the casements where they had mostly artillery
在另一边有一个姊妹要塞——拉法叶堡，也就是现在大桥布鲁克林侧塔楼所在地
and it's there was a sister fort on the other side Fort Lafayette
and that was where the towers to the Brooklyn side of the bridge are now resting
独立后，又过了一百年
after Independence there would still be another hundred years
史坦顿岛才正式成为纽约市的一部分
before Staten Island was part of New York City
在此期间，史坦顿岛诞生了科尼利厄斯·范德比尔特，
during this time Staten Island was a birthplace of Cornelius Vanderbilt
他是这个新国家最早的白手起家的商业巨头之一
one of the first self-made tycoons in the new country
通过控制和整合庞大的铁路及航运网络，
by controlling and consolidating large networks of railroads and shipping
他在19世纪成为了世界上最富有的人之一
he became one of the wealthiest men in the world during the 1800s
因为出生在史坦顿岛，很容易看出是什么引导他走向了那个方向：
and being from Staten Island it's easy to see what pointed him in that direction
史坦顿岛作为一个岛屿，周围一直都有渡轮在运营
Staten Island being an island has always had faeries all the way around
直到1880年代末铁路桥开通之前，
there were no Bridges until
这里都没有桥梁连接
a railroad bridge opened up in the late 1880s
曼哈顿、布鲁克林和新泽西一直是史坦顿岛农产品的市场
Manhattan Brooklyn and New Jersey were always the markets for Staten Island's Goods
所以渡轮在史坦顿岛人的生活中一直扮演着至关重要的角色，
so the faeries were always playing a very important role in the lives of Staten Islanders
因为这里曾是一个农业社区
because it was a farming Community
这里一直是个农业社区，直到19世纪初，工业开始在北岸和东岸兴起，
it was an agricultural Community until the early 1800s when industry started popping up along the North Shore and the East Shore
渡轮在接送人员往返方面非常重要，
so the faeries were important in bringing people back and forth
尤其是对农民来说
but especially for the farmers
范德比尔特年仅16岁时就创办了自己的渡轮公司，
when he was only 16 Vanderbilt started his own Ferry company
后来他的儿子在尝试通过铁路将史坦顿岛与纽约连接起来方面发挥了重要作用
and later his son played a large role in trying to connect Staten Island to New York by rail
我们在布鲁克林的视频中看过这张人口图表，我想再带大家看一遍
we looked at this population graph in the Brooklyn video but I want to look at it again
你可以看到，虽然布鲁克林和曼哈顿的人口在这一百年里增长迅速，
you can see that while the population of Brooklyn and Manhattan grew quickly during these hundred years
但史坦顿岛的增长缓慢，和其他区一样，因为它主要专注于农业 and 小型制造业
Staten Islands increased slowly along with the other Bros since it was primarily focused on Farming and small-scale Manufacturing
同样在此期间，这里的桑迪地（Sandy Ground）社区开始发展，
also during this time the neighborhood right here known as Sandy ground began to develop
成为美国最早的自由黑人社区之一
as one of the earliest free black communities in the US
荷兰人在纽约市地区蓄养了很多奴隶
the Dutch had a lot of slaves in the New York City area
这是17世纪的一个事实，被认为是日常生活的一部分，
it's a matter of a fact of the 17th century it was considered daily life
但我认为历史学家常因为它太丑陋而略过它
but it's one that I think historians gloss over cuz it's ugly
在我看来，史坦顿岛上一直都有被奴役的人，
as far as I'm concerned there have been ens slaved people since on Staten Island
甚至在建立永久定居点之前就有
you know before um before even permanent settlement
尽管在1963年遭遇了大火，
despite being devastated by fire in 1963 Sandy ground
桑迪地现在仍是最初创始人后代的家园
is still home to some of the descendants of its original Founders
同样，因为史坦顿岛离市区相对较近，且有这些高低起伏的山丘，
also because Staten Island is relatively close to the city and has these big hilly Bluffs
它成了富有的纽约人建造夏季度假房的热门地点
it became a popular spot for wealthy New Yorkers to build summer homes
圣乔治地区的很多房子现在依然矗立着，
a lot of these houses are still standing in the St George area
非常漂亮，拥有无敌的城市景观
and they're beautiful and have incredible views of the city
这是我的两个问题的答案开始交织在一起的地方
this is where the answer to both of my questions starts to blend into one
史坦顿岛成为纽约市的一部分之所以能被提上日程，
Staten and becoming part of the city of New York is only even on the table
唯一的原因是史坦顿岛已经是纽约州的一部分了，我叫肯·戈尔德（Ken Gold）
because Staten is's already a part of New York State my name is Ken Gold
我是一名美国城市教育历史学家
I'm a historian of American Urban education
我一直在史坦顿岛学院任教，目前担任正教授，
I have been teaching at the College of Staten Island where I currently serve as a full professor
也是2023年出版的《被遗忘的行政区》一书的作者
and I'm the author of the 2023 publication the Forgotten burough
史坦顿岛就在地铁图上
stat is in the subway
我们现在所知的城市边界是在1898年创建的，
the city boundary as we know it was created in 1898
当时该地区所有的城市和城镇被合并为一个
when all of the cities and towns within the area were Consolidated into one
合并之后，他们将县治（即政府所在地）搬到了渡轮旁的圣乔治，
and then after consolidation they moved the county seat which is the seat of government to St George
因为那里靠近曼哈顿
by the ferry because of its proximity to Manhattan
行政大楼（Borough Hall）就在这里，
this is where bro Hall is the first building that was pointed out to me after getting off the ferry
这是我下渡轮后向我指出的第一栋建筑
合并很大程度上是安德鲁·哈斯韦尔·格林（Andrew Haswell Green）努力的结果，
consolidation was largely the result of the efforts of Andrew Haswell green
他希望创建一个统一的政府实体来管理整个港口
who wanted to create a single governmental entity that would control the harbor In Our Lifetime right
在我们的有生之年，对吧？自由市场常被标榜为效率的保障，
free markets get presented as uh the mechanism for efficiency
而公共部门则被描述为臃肿、低效的实体
and sort of the public sector gets you know presented as this bloated inefficient entity
但120年前，安德鲁·哈斯韦尔·格林的观点恰恰相反
um but 120 years ago Andrew haswell's greens was exactly the opposite
他的地理视角是整个纽约港
his Geographic vantage point was the harbor of New York City
如果那是你的视角，如果你观察那个港口，
and if you that's your Vantage Point uh and you look at the harbor
那么港口的入口就是纳罗斯海峡，而史坦顿岛就守在那个入口
then the entrance of that Harbor right is the ver the narrow straet and Staton lies at that entrance
这就是为什么他总是把史坦顿岛包含在他的纽约合并提案中，
and that's why he always included it in his uh proposal to consolidate New York
并且在一度有一些曼哈顿人推动将其排除在外时，他据理力争将其保留下来
and fought to keep it when uh at one point there were some manhattanites who were pushing for its exclusion
史坦顿岛人期望加入城市后能获得很多好处
Staten Islanders expected a lot of benefits from joining the city
我认为史坦顿岛的人民投票决定
I think the the people of Staten Island voted
成为纽约市的一部分，
to become part of the city of New York
是因为他们期望城市
because they expected that the city would help
能帮助这个区进步和改善
the burrow advance and improve
史坦顿岛希望
st9 was hoping that
作为纽约市的一部分，
as part of New York City
能获得大量的市政资金
they would get a lot of Municipal funds
用于下水道、道路等基础设施建设
for sewers roads and the like
你可以看到合并后不久皇后区和布朗克斯区的增长
you can see the growth of queens and the Bronx shortly after consolidation
它们都享受到了成为城市一部分
they both enjoyed the benefits of being part of the city
以及与地铁系统连接带来的好处
and being linked with the subway system
但史坦顿岛从未连接到地铁
but Staten Island was never connected to the subway
你知道，这导致了某种程度的孤立
you know it leads to kind of of a level of isolation
在经济发展方面是经济孤立，
right the city you know it's economic isolation
搬到这里的人变少了，
in terms of its Economic Development
也是文化孤立
it's you know fewer people moving here
it's cultural isolation
我总是很惊讶，
I'm always amazed at how many students I've taught
我教过的学生中有多少人竟然从未去过曼哈顿
that I teach that have never been to Manhattan
我们在今天的地铁图上看到的唯一一条线，
the one line we see on today's subway map
其实是比地铁早50年建造的一条铁路线
was a rail line built 50 years before the subway
史坦顿岛比其他区更远，
Staten is further than the other buus
所以我不认为
and so I I don't think
它的人口会变得像皇后区
it would have become as populous as queens
或布朗克斯区那么多
or the Bronx
但我认为它本来应该在几十年前就达到50万人口，
but I think it would have hit half a million decades ago
而不是像现在这样还没完全达到
instead of still not quite being there
让我感到震惊的是，
what's striking for me to learn about the development of Staten Island
了解到史坦顿岛的发展其实是非常近期的事，
is just how recent it's been
是的，我亲身经历过
yeah I mean I lived through it
我亲历了史坦顿岛所谓的“农耕时期”
I I lived through the the so-called farming period on Staten Island
当我79年搬到这里时，还有经营中的农场
when I moved here in 79 there was an active farm
当我开车去朋友家时，
and as I was driving to a friend's house
我看到一群牛在史坦顿岛购物中心的草坪上吃草，
I saw a herd of cows grazing on the St Island Mall
那可是1979年了
the grass of the mall as late as 79
史坦顿岛依然是目前为止最像农村的行政区
Staten Island is still easily the most rural burrow
我知道这是一个奇怪的衡量方式，
and I know this is a weird way to measure it
但当我在谷歌地图上闲逛时，
but when I was poking around on Google Maps
我总能看到这些游泳池
I kept seeing all these swimming pools
于是我查了一下，发现了这张地图
so I looked it up and I found this map
史坦顿岛是一个明显的离群值
Staten Island is a clear outlier
看看这些地上泳池
look at all of these ground pools
显然这可能有多种原因，
obviously there could be multiple reasons for this
但有空间去做这件事，
but the fact that there's space to do it
我觉得说明了一些问题
I think says something
尽管未开发的地貌标志着它与城市其他部分的距离，
although the undeveloped landscape marked its distance from the rest of the city
但这同时也成了史坦顿岛人的骄傲
it also became a point point of Pride for the Staten Islanders
这里感觉像是一个绿意盎然的小镇社区，
it felt like a small neighborhood town with a lot of greenery
如果你见过1960年代的特拉维斯和托滕维尔镇，
if you ever saw the towns of Travis and Tottenville back in the 1960s
你会以为自己身处中西部
you would have thought you were out in the midwest
保护这些景观的努力催生了绿带（Green Belt），
efforts to preserve this led to the green belt
即岛中心这片巨大的绿色区域
this large green area in the center of the island
我想指出这片自然保护区中心
and I want to point out an interesting landmark
的一个有趣的标志性建筑
in the center of this Nature Preserve
这是海景医院（Sea View Hospital）旧址，
this is the site of C viw Hospital
曾是全国最大的结核病疗养机构
the nation's largest tuberculosis facility
它专门建在这里，
and it was spefic specifically built here
是因为当时人们认为治疗结核病的方法是阳光和新鲜空气
because the cure to tuberculosis was believed to be sunshine and fresh air
你住在这里，地势这么高，
you're up to here this high
你会得到大量的新鲜空气和阳光
you're going to get a lot of fresh air and a lot of sunshine
最初建了八栋医院大楼，
and originally there were eight hospitals buildings built
四栋女用，四栋男用，
four for female four for male
这很有意思
which was interesting
在那个年代，他们实行男女隔离
they segregated the sexes in those days
我们说的是1910年、1911年左右
we talking about 1910 1911
因为我们处在城市中一个非常偏僻的地方，
since we're in a very isolated a part of the city
周围没有太多给员工住的房子，
there weren't many housing out there for staff
所以大多数员工就住在这个院区里
so most of staff lived right here on this campus
这个设施的历史超级有趣，也相当阴森，
the history of this facility is super interesting and pretty creepy
哇，吓到我了
whoa that spooked me
是道，我还没准备好
yeah I know I wasn't ready for that
但这是当初的一个原始担架
but this is one of the original gurns
这是结核病时期他们使用的一些工具的展示
this is uh a display of some of the tools they used during the tuberculosis days
看看这个锯子，这是用来锯骨头的
I mean look at this soore this was used to cut bone
他们曾经还有一个胎儿标本
they also had a fetus once
那个已经不在这里了，
that is no longer here
因为那让人们感到不安，总之
cuz that was getting people upset anyway
总之，缺乏地铁开始解释了
anyway the lack of Subway begins to explain
这里为什么是“被遗忘的行政区”
the reason this was the Forgotten bur
但还有另外两个主要原因，
but there's a couple other major reasons
我给你们三秒钟猜猜谁该为此负责：
and I'll give you three seconds to guess
罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）
who's responsible for them Robert Moses
那位权力大得离谱的公园委员会专员
the weirdly powerful Parks commissioner
然后摩西先生在1948年说：
and then Mr Moses in 1948 said
我们要把垃圾填埋场设在史坦顿岛的
we are putting a landfill on Staten Island
鲜杀（Fresh Kills）
in the fresh kills
我们要叫它鲜杀填埋场
we're going to call the fresh kills landfill
他们没用“垃圾堆”这个词
they didn't use the word dump
在那个时候，人们还热衷于填平湿地
and at that point people were still interested in filling up Wetlands
他们认为湿地是没用的
they thought Wetlands were useless
在接下来的50年里，
and for the next 50 years
鲜杀湿地被改造成了世界上最大的垃圾填埋场，
the fresh kill Wetlands were transformed into the world's largest landfill
就在史坦顿岛上
right on Staten Island
填埋场代表了这样一种想法：你永远不会想起我们，
the landfill represented this idea of you never you never do you know think about us
除非是为了建造
unless it's to sort of build something
一些没人想要的东西
that nobody else wants
摩西做的另一件事是对史坦顿岛影响最深远的事，可能是有史以来最深远的
the other thing Moses did was
the most impact thing to happen to Staten Island probably ever
我不想称之为“成就”
now I'm not going to call it achievement
但最重大的事件是
but the the crowning event was
连接布鲁克林和史坦顿岛的韦拉扎诺海峡大桥的开通，
the opening of the verzano narrow bridge
它永远改变了
between Brooklyn and Staten Island
史坦顿岛
which changed Staten Island for ever
韦拉扎诺海峡大桥建成时是世界上最长的悬索桥
the verzano neros bridge was the longest suspension bridge in the world when it was built
从那以后，史坦顿岛的人口翻了一番还多
and the population of Staten Island has more than doubled since then
在大桥建成前后，人口出现了爆炸式增长
the population exploded around the time the bridge was built
史坦顿岛人通常分为“桥前派” and “桥后派”，
and the Staten Islanders are usually divided into before the bridge and after the bridge folks
大桥是64年建成的，但在那之前由于人们预期大桥建成，迁入潮就已经开始了
Bridge went up in ' 64
the influx started a little bit before the bridge
大桥是64年建成的，但在那之前由于人们预期大桥建成，迁入潮就已经开始了
people anticipating it being built and being finished
但在大桥建成后，人口彻底爆发了
but it exploded after the bridge
因为现在你过桥只要5分钟，
because now the access you can get across the bridge in what 5 minutes
而以前从布鲁克林坐渡轮需要超过半小时
as opposed to taking the ferry which was from Brooklyn
was more than a half an hour
人们没有意识到，
people didn't realize that
我指的是史坦顿岛土生土长的人
when I say people I mean the people who are native Staten Islanders
他们没有意识到将会发生怎样的变化
they didn't realize the changes that were going to occur
他们没有意识到这种略带田园气息的环境
they didn't realize that this somewhat bucolic setting
几乎一夜之间就会改变
was going to practically change overnight
他们对摩西
and they developed a very strong resentment towards Moses
以及从布鲁克林搬来的人产生了强烈的怨恨
towards people who moved from Brooklyn
我们有成千上万的人因为这座桥
and there were thousands of us who moved from Brooklyn
从布鲁克林搬了过来
because of the bridge
我不想称之为“仇恨”
I don't want to call it hatred
但那种对布鲁克林人、对摩西以及对所发生变化的厌恶
but that dislike of of you know brooklynites and Moses
依然存在
and the changes that have occurred is still present
我的意思是，现在已经是大桥开通60周年了
I mean it's what we the 60th anniversary of the opening of the bridge
它依然存在
and it's still present
因为史坦顿岛原住民的心态就是：
because that's the mindset of the Native Staten Islanders
摩西和布鲁克林人毁了史坦顿岛
is that Moses and the brooklynites destroyed ston Island
韦拉扎诺（Verrazzano）是第一位进入该海港的意大利探险家
verzo was an Italian explorer who first entered the harbor
所以他们以他的名字命名了大桥
and so therefore they named it after him
但我想当时有个拼写错误
but there was a typo I guess
决定订制标识牌的人
well the the person who decided who ordered the signs
没有研究韦拉扎诺名字的正确拼写
didn't research the correct spelling of Arizon
我想它有两个 R 和两个 Z，
I think has two RS and two Z's
而他们漏掉了一个字母，
and they left one of them out one of the letters out
不过没关系
that's okay
这座大桥的建设伴随着横跨全岛的高速公路
the construction of this bridge came along with expressways through the island
这里的史坦顿岛高速公路、
the Staten Island Expressway here
西岸高速公路以及马丁·路德·金二世高速公路
the West Shore Expressway and the Dr Martin Luther King Jr Expressway
在60年代经历这一切，
living through that in the 60s
看着所有的老农场消失，
and watching all the old Farms disappear
树木被砍倒，
and the trees being knocked down
湿地被填平
and the wetlands being filled in
真的挺让人震撼的
it was pretty mindblowing
特别是对于像我这样一个从小就对历史 and 自然
especially for somebody who had already had an interest in history
感兴趣的人来说
and nature at such a young age
但这一切的目的更多是为了绕过曼哈顿
but the purpose of all of this was more to bypass Manhattan
前往长岛，
to get to Long Island
而不是真正为了连接史坦顿岛本身
rather than actually accessing Staten Island itself
很多史坦顿岛居民认为史坦顿岛是一个“飞越地带”，
a lot of the Staten Island residents consider statown a flyover country
人们只是嗖地一下穿过这里
where people just zip through here
前往新泽西或南方港口
to get to New jerse Jersey and Port South
但史坦顿岛从盘古开天辟地以来一直就是这样
but that's been true since the beginning of time on Staten Island
还有另一条罗伯特·摩西想建造的高速公路
there was another Expressway that Robert Moses wanted to build
——里士满高速公路
the Richmond Expressway
它本会切断绿带的中心
it would have cut through the center of the green belt
多亏了环保团体，它才没能实现
thanks to conservation groups it never happened
但你仍然可以看到
but you can still see the on andof ramps
为了预见它而建造的上下匝道
that were built in anticipation of it
1993年，“被遗忘的行政区”这种感觉
in 1993 the feeling of being the Forgotten burrow
变得昭然若揭
was made crystal clear
这与一个世纪前他们加入城市的初衷
this was in stark contrast to the original interest
形成了鲜明对比
they had in joining the city a century earlier
1894年，近五分之四的选民
in 1894 nearly four out of five voters
（78%）投票赞成
78% voted in favor
与纽约市合并
of consolidating with New York City
而100年后，史坦顿岛出现了一场脱离运动
and then 100 years later there's a secession movement on Staten Island
在1993年的全民公投中，
it's about 2third of the people in the 1993 referendum
约有三分之二的人说：我们想要脱离
who say we want to disconnect
所以，在岛屿对待城市其他部分的态度方面，
so right something has transformed
确实发生了一些转变
uh in terms of the islands attitude
towards the rest of the city
最终，州政府阻止了脱离
ultimately the state blocked the secession
次年，鲜杀填埋场被关闭
and the next year the fresh kills landfill was closed
在访问了史坦顿岛并与这些专家交谈后，
after visiting Staten Island and talking with these experts
我觉得我的问题有了答案
I feel like I have answers to my questions
今天有些人争论说我们当初根本不该加入纽约市
some people argue today we should never have joined the city
我不知道那样行不行得通
I'm not I I don't know whether that that have worked or not
但是，现在这是一个美丽的地方，
but um this is a beautiful spot
虽然也很冷，正值日落
in a very cold spot right now it's a sunset
史坦顿岛南端有一场美丽的日落，
there a beautiful sunset here on the south TR stat Island
非常感谢收看
thank you so much for watching
制作这些视频需要耗费大量的时间和精力
these videos take a lot of time and a lot of work
所以如果你已经看到了这里，
so if you've made it to this point
如果你还没订阅，那真的有点说不过去
it's kind of offensive if you haven't subscribed
我觉得，顺便给视频点个赞吧
I think and liked the video
非常感谢我所有的 Patreon 支持者
huge thank you to all of my patreon supporters
如果你有兴趣支持我，链接在下方
it's linked below if you're interested in supporting me there
在那里你还能找到帮助我的所有专家的书籍
alongside it you'll find link to the books
and 网站链接
and sites of all of the experts that helped me
非常感谢你们每一个人，你们太棒了
huge thank you to each of you you're amazing
一个没能放进视频的趣闻是
one fun fact that didn't fit into the video
关于奥特布里奇跨海大桥（Outerbridge Crossing）的名字，
is the name of Outerbridge Crossing
就是这里的这座桥
which is the bridge right here
很容易想当然地认为它为什么叫这个名字
it's easy to assume why it's called
（以为是“外面的桥”）
the Outerbridge Crossing
但实际上 Outerbridge 是一个人的姓氏，
but actually Outerbridge is someone's last name
那个人有个女儿在1870年代去了百慕大，
and that person had a daughter
发现了一项叫网球的小众运动
who went to Bermuda in the 1870s
and found a little sport called tennis
然后她带回了一些设备并在史坦顿岛打球，
and then brought back some equipment and played it on stat Island
第一次将网球引入了美国，
introducing the United States to tennis
感谢收看，再见
for the very first time thanks for watching bye